The year was 1983, and seven year old Andrea
Bradbury was wandering the streets of Nashville,
Tennessee.
One of her favourite activities was to head
down to the local movie theater and fantasize
about the movies she’d one day be old enough
to see.
This fateful weekend, Andrea’s local theater
was playing a brand new release: Jaws 3D.
What she didn’t know is that this simple,
innocent activity would bring little Andrea
into dangerous contact with SCP - 178 and
change her life forever.
Jaws 3D isn’t exactly a classic - it was
one of the many forgettable sequels pumped
out to cash in on the 3D craze of the early
1980s.
People paid extra for the privilege of sitting
in the dark with an uncomfortable pair of
cardboard glasses while cheesy effects leapt
out of the screen towards them.
Many of the moviegoers simply threw away the
cheap, disposable glasses as soon as they
left the theater, leaving them scattered on
the sidewalk outside.
Seeing a pair of 3D glasses on the ground,
right there for the taking, was the highlight
of little Andrea’s week.
She may not have been old enough to see any
of the movies, but she knew that a local shop
sold books with images that popped off the
page with a simple pair of 3D glasses.
Excited by the prospect of getting to experience
3D, Andrea grabbed a pair of glasses and ran
straight for the bookstore.
Later that night, she was in her bedroom,
with a stereoscopic image of a Ferris wheel..
Andrea adjusted the glasses - and the Ferris
wheel really did pop right off the page.
She marveled at the image coming out of the
book and felt like she could almost touch
it.
But suddenly a strange feeling came over her.
She had the feeling that she wasn’t… alone.
Still wearing the glasses, Andrea looked up
from her book and saw it, standing in the
corner of her room.
Something huge.
Something monstrous.
Andrea’s parents heard her scream and came
rushing into her room.
There was their little girl, dead.
It looked like she’d been mauled to death
by a wild animal, but there was no sign of
her killer.
The windows were shut tight, unable to be
opened from outside.
It was like whatever horrible creature had
done this had vanished into thin air.
The coroner's report didn’t give any other
clues as to who could have done this, except
that whoever, or whatever had murdered her,
it appeared to have three long and incredibly
sharp claws.
The terrible tragedy of Andrea’s death rocked
Nashville, but it never made the national
papers.
Why?
Because the SCP Foundation was immediately
on the case.
Undercover agents in the US Fish and Wildlife
Service flagged the strange death as anomalous,
and SCP field personnel arrived to do their
own investigation of the crime scene.
There they quickly discovered Andrea’s 3D
glasses - which would eventually be classified
as SCP - 178.
An Agent looked over the glasses.
There didn’t seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them, just your regular
cardboard frames with blue and red tinted
film over the eyes.
Everything about them seemed normal, so he
tried the glasses on himself.
He picked up the open book up off the ground
where Andrea had likely dropped it, and saw
the Ferris wheel pop up off the page.
Nothing abnormal.
Until he turned his head slightly...
He saw the head of some kind of… thing,
only an inch away from his own, looking over
his shoulder at the book.
Being a trained SCP agent, he maintained his
composure, and looked around the room.
As he did he saw that several other creatures
were standing and watching.
None of the rest of the recovery team seemed
to notice the creatures, and when the agent
removed SCP - 178, they vanished.
It appeared that they had found whatever had
caused Andrea Bradbury’s death.
The glasses were immediately taken to the
nearest Foundation containment site for further
testing.
Seeing these mysterious entities through SCP
- 178 may have answered one question, but
it raised many others.
What are these creatures?
Were they real, or merely illusions created
by SCP - 178?
If they are real, are they somehow summoned
by SCP - 178, or simply revealed by them?
There was already one death that could be
tied to the glasses with some certainty, but
just how dangerous were they?
The SCP Foundation was about to find out.
Foundation scientists devised a series of
experiments, with a test chamber separated
from an adjoining observation chamber by a
panel of reinforced bulletproof glass.
A member of D-Class personnel was placed into
the test chamber, along with SCP - 178.
He was instructed to put on the glasses and
report what he saw back to the researchers.
The D-Class followed the orders, however when
he did so, he quickly entered a state of extreme
distress.
He threw away the glasses and covered his
eyes, screaming wildly.
When ordered to compose himself and explain
what he saw under threat of termination, the
D-Class described a “hideous” creature
standing close to his face, watching.
When asked to elaborate, he described it as
having “too many eyes.”
After that, the D-Class refused to put the
glasses back on again, despite direct orders
and threats from Foundation staff.
He was then removed from the test chamber
and observed.
Although he experienced two days of mild paranoia,
after thirty total days of observation the
D-Class was found to have no long lasting
psychological effects.
Disappointed by the meager results of the
first test, the researchers had at least confirmed
that they did indeed have an anomalous object
in their possession, and pressed on with the
experiments.
They used the same methodology again on another
D-Class.
She was placed into the chamber and instructed
to put on SCP - 178, then describe the entity
she saw in great detail.
When she put on the glasses she recoiled in
horror at the monster she saw staring back
at her.
She said that the creature was tall and bipedal,
with two additional upper appendages ending
in large conical protrusions.
She also described the creature’s head as
being “smooth.”
When asked if the creature exhibited any kind
of aggression or hostility, she said that
it was completely still.
It was just standing there.
After a few minutes though, the creature seemed
to lose interest, and began staring at the
wall.
The researchers were happy to learn more about
the creature’s physicality, but they still
weren’t confident that it wasn’t just
an illusion created by the glasses.
They needed to engineer an interaction.
For the next experiment, they decided to alter
the particulars.
A fractal blue and red image, in a similar
style to the stereoscopic Ferris wheel from
the book Andrea had purchased was fixed to
one wall.
Against the opposite wall, they placed a bucket
containing ten standard tennis balls.
This time, the D-Class - a convicted murderer
and arsonist - was told that he was helping
to test a new 3D augmented reality project.
The entities he would see, as far as he knew,
were little more than digital projections.
Though when he actually wore SCP - 178 and
saw them, he commented that whoever designed
them must be crazy.
The researchers instructed the D-Class to
pick up a tennis ball and throw it at one
of the entities.
The second he did so, deep lacerations began
appearing all over his body.
The onslaught was brutal and quick, and the
D-Class was dead soon after that.
This confirmed to the researchers that the
creatures did seem to have some level of tangible
presence, and they could be extremely violent
if provoked.
Next, they wished to see if it was possible
to have any kind of interaction with the creatures
without it immediately descending into violence.
To test this theory, the researchers brought
a nineteen year old D-Class into the testing
chamber under the same pretence of testing
new 3D technology.
Much like the others, she was still horrified
by the appearance of the creatures, but was
calmed down by the researchers.
They asked her to speak to the creatures directly,
without exhibiting any kind of aggression.
She said, “Hello, weird thing, how are you
today?” in a somewhat bored voice.
And this was all it took to sign her death
warrant - she was immediately slashed to death
by invisible creatures.
The results seemed clear: Any interaction
whatsoever with the creatures while wearing
SCP - 178 was a death sentence, like a slightly
more outgoing Shy Guy.
But the researchers would soon find that this
anomaly had even more surprises.
For their next test, they brought in two subjects:
One would wear SCP - 178, and dictate to the
other how they should interact with a creature
they could not see.
The results of this experiment were bloody,
yet informative.
Both subjects were slashed to death when the
unseeing D-Class interacted with one of the
creatures on her companion’s instructions.
It appeared that anyone with sufficient knowledge
of the creatures who attempts to interact
with them is doomed, even if they can’t
directly see one of them.
It was an upsetting realization for the researchers:
SCP - 178 may be much more dangerous than
they initially imagined.
And what they’d learn in the next experiment
was even worse.
They adopted the same methodology as the last
for the following experiment - two subjects,
one seeing and the other interacting.
However, this time, as soon as Subject number
one put on the glasses, they knew that something
was terribly wrong.
He began panicking, stating that the entire
chamber was full of the creatures, all standing
and watching.
The researchers undertook these experiments
knowing that they didn’t often turn out
well for the D-Class, so they didn’t seem
too worried about this new development…
that is until the subject stated that they
could see three more of the creatures, and
they weren’t in the test chamber.
They were in the observation room.
In fact, one of them was looking right over
one of the three researchers’ shoulders.
Immediately, the researchers lost composure
and began to panic.
They were used to putting D-Class in danger,
that was part of the job, but they weren’t
prepared for this!
In just moments, the observation room became
a bloodbath as the three researchers who’d
been designing and performing all the experiments
were torn to pieces by creatures they couldn’t
see
SCP - 178 had gone from being one of the more
innocent looking anomalies to one of the most
mysterious and deadly.
The creatures seemed to be powerful, violent,
and incredibly numerous.
The fact that they can only be observed through
178’s stereoscopic lenses and kill anyone
who even attempts to interact with them makes
them almost impossible to understand.
It was always a tragedy when the Foundation
lost good researchers, but the work must continue,
and the experiments were soon restarted with
increased safety measures.
Of course those didn’t do much good, and
after another disastrous experiment that resulted
in the whole sector getting locked down, all
research into SCP - 178 was placed under increased
scrutiny.
They needed to find some way of observing
the creatures, without the risk of having
to share space with them.
The proposed solution was seeing if the SCP
- 178 glasses were compatible with camera
technology for remote viewing.
Much like all stereoscopic glasses, they found
that looking through only one lens at a time
was ineffective.
The solution was relatively simple: A dual-lens
camera in a roughly similar configuration
to human eyes.
This, however, didn’t give them the comfort,
or the answers they hoped for.
Researchers commented, upon finally seeing
the creatures, that they were even more hideous
than they’d ever imagined.
As they observed a victim interacting with
the creatures via their new camera, they found
that as soon as the creatures were interacted
with in any way, they would grow three long
claws and attack.
And they were as fast as they were ferocious.
From the observations, there were only a few
things that the Foundation now knew about
them for sure: Their physical appearance,
their violent nature, their enhanced physical
abilities, and the fact they appear to be
pretty much everywhere.
And who knows how long they’d been here,
observing us humans while we glided by them,
ignorant to their presence?
It’s enough to make you think twice before
putting on a pair of 3D glasses again.
But of course, never putting on the glasses
doesn’t mean you’re safe.
Just knowing about them puts you in danger.
They could be standing next to you right now,
looking over your shoulder as you watch this
video.
Just remember: If you want to be safe, you
can’t ever let them know you’re aware.
After all, just because you can’t see something,
doesn’t mean it can’t hurt you.
Now go check out “SCP - 049 - The Plague
Doctor Captured” and “SCP - 087 - The
Stairwell” for some other creepy creatures
from SCP Explained!